Hey! I hope you're enjoying the lesson so far.
So, every week we make lessons like this one to help you to understand your favorite series
without subtitles just like the law who says
that since he joined his confidence
speaking English and even his
performance in his master's program have
greatly increased so remember to hit that subscribe button and the bell down below
so you don't miss any of our new
lessons do you want me to wear your
So, I wanted to take the time to tell you about a big opportunity that we have for you up until July 20th.
If you find grammar pronunciation and
vocabulary explanations like these helpful,
and you enjoy our method of making learning English fun with your favorite series like friends.
then our fluency course Fluent with Friends
is perfect for you
you'll get the confidence that you need to understand the natives at any speed.
Without getting lost
without missing the jokes and without
subtitles
just like Allember, who says
that since he joined he's learning like
never before so much more than at the
academies that he studied at.
When you joined Fluent with Friends you would learn
with the 48 full episodes from the first
two seasons from friends.
Every week you will get a 20-plus page PDF power lesson like this one
innovative vocabulary memorization software,
access to our global Fluency Circle community and so much more!
plus, if you join this Standard or Complete packages
You also get weekly video lessons teaching you
with the best scenes from each episode
that's over 56 exclusive video lessons
very similar to the ones that you find
here but you will not find these ones on
YouTube and they include over 13 hours of materials
To thank you for your support and to celebrate over 750
thousand subscribers here at Learn English
with TV series
As a part of Fluency Week we are offering you a 33% discount of Fluent with Friends
You just have to use the coupon code 700k at checkout
What would it feel like if next year you could understand your favorite series without subtitles
or have a conversation with an American without having to ask her to slow down
Don't wait. Join Fluent with Friends now.
I look forward to seeing you in the Fluency Circle
Now, let's get back to the lesson.
All right, so now it's time for you to test
everything you learned
by watching the scene a final
time without subtitles
but this time we're also throwing in a bit of a quiz so at certain moments we will pause the
video to ask you different questions you
will have a few seconds to answer each
question before we showed the correct
answer on the screen be sure to tell us
what you thought about this because it's
the first time we're doing it and let us
know what score you got on the quiz.
All right are you ready let's roll the quiz
Alright, how did you do?
Remember to tell us your score, and what you thought about that quiz down in the comments below.
And also remember that Fluency Week
ends July 20th.
So, it's the last chance to get that 33% discount on our Fluent with Friends course,
so that we can join you on your mission to speak
and understand English confidently learn
more and sign up for the course
and remember to get your 33% discount you
just have to use the coupon code 700k
at checkout
now it's time to go beyond the
classroom and live your English, aww yeah!